[Musique]
ling et gaston font des rénovations ils
ont signé un contrat avec cet
entrepreneur mais son travail est bâclé
les délais exagéré en plus il est où
traînait peuvent-ils résilier ce contrat
alors que le travail a commencé
oui l'article 21 25 du code civil du
québec permet de résilier un contrat
d'entreprise de service sans avoir à
donner de raison évidemment ligne et
gaston doivent payer les travaux déjà
exécutés mais pas plus l'entrepreneur ne
peut pas réclamer la perte de son profit
c'est la loi
certains entrepreneurs se protègent
contre une résiliation en ajoutant
clause qui vous oblige à renoncer à
votre droit alors si vous tenez à le
conserver
lisez bien le contrat avant de signer le
contrat de ligne et gaston ne contenait
pas cette clause
ils ont réussi à s'entendre avec
l'entrepreneur le fin mot de l'histoire
vous pouvez éviter les supplices et
résilier un contrat d'entreprise ou de
services